make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
what I want to do here is is I want to
dip my toes in the water of talking
about the fulcrum in Marvel Comics and
the reason why is because the fulcrum is
largely considered to be an aspect of
the one above all insofar as the one
above all you don't really see that
frequently in Marvel comics but you do
see the fulcrum right and so the
question that people usually ask is if
the one above all kind of exists in the
Marvel multiverse then what's it doing
whenever it's not popping up and talking
to anybody the fulcrum is supposedly the
answer to that question right like
here's what the one above all does what
it's just kind of you know it doesn't
like a regular basis on a regular date
here's what the one above all does in
Marvel comics like this bit of an
explanation the introduction of the
fulcrum actually came out of the
Eternals volume four that was written by
Charles Knopf I think it is is KN au F
not really sure exactly how to pronounce
that that name but um there's a couple
different things that are explained here
right so this is really gonna be more of
a the fulcrum explained as opposed to
like a traditional you know kind of
storytelling video kind of hybrid
between the two but the way this works
is that in Marvel Comics back at this
point in time this story was written
2008 so as before everything like
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers the introduction of the
builders secret Wars like Al Ewing's run
on The Ultimates and all that kind of
stuff back at this point in time when
this story was written we did not have
an origin for the Celestials we had
multiple origins right there were
different stories out there in terms of
how the Celestials came into existence
there were some stories that said that
the Celestials had basically created the
entirety of the multiverse right there
were other stories that said the
Celestials came into existence at the
same time the sentient life was
developing on various worlds and they
just achieved a super high level of
technology that allow them to transcend
a physical form and become these you
know ultra powerful cosmic beings that
basically were made up of complete and
pure energy right and so they kind of
formed these physical bodies or to give
themself a shape more recently the
definitive origin of the Celestials is
that they were created by the first
universe right they were originally the
aspirants some rebelled and then call
themselves Celestials and that's how you
get their origin but nonetheless the
idea here is that at this point in time
there's no definitive origin or at least
this is one of one of many you know
ideas of how they function
but the Celestials at that point in time
existed as a kind of yin and yang right
if the Celestials were the yin then the
Horde
the yen they were basically the opposite
of the Celestials but the Celestials
were basically beings of creation and
the idea was that when the Celestials
traveled around the cosmos they
essentially would go from planet to
planet and they would modify 300 members
of that planetary race right so in the
instance of humanity they showed up you
know some however many you know millions
of years ago or how many thousands of
years ago one say was like thirty
thousand years ago and came across a
group called The Wanderers and The
Wanderers were kind of this missing link
between real primate man and modern man
and so the Celestials modified their
genes and basically took 1/3 of the
Wanderers and made them deviants took
another third and made them eternals and
then took the final third and then
basically modified their genes to it at
a future point in time they would
basically you know those genes would
start activating and then that's how we
got the origin of the mutant population
in Marvel Comics the results of this is
that for years and years and years and
Marvel that was the status quo and then
after some period of time the Celestials
would come back they would judge the
planet and if it was deemed to be a
failure they were destroyed what this
does is it introduces the notion of the
Horde and the Horde was this idea that
that were the Celestials were basically
beings of creation and the the Horde
were beings of destruction that the
fulcrum was the one they both served and
the idea was that when this took off
when it really kind of happened that
essentially after nineteen cosmic cycles
as is described and I don't think Marvel
ever really establishes how long a
cosmic cycle is if it's like a millennia
or something along those lines but
regardless whatever a cosmic cycle takes
place that after nineteen of those
essentially the planet itself is more or
less harvested right like the energies
of the planet or at least its essence is
kind of sent back to the fulcrum in
order to give the fulcrum an indication
of what the planet is if the planet is
largely composed of deviants me that
there are no eternals there anymore only
the deviants are left then the life
force is basically given to the Horde if
the planet is mostly composed of
eternals or completely composed of
Eternals that life force is sent to the
Celestials and so the question is kind
of how does this work okay after
nineteen cosmic cycles the the Horde is
sent to a plant and the Horde will in
turn basically destroy that plant
they'll consume all life on that planet
and when it happens when all life is
basically eradicated whatever the life
energies of those beings are are given
to the Horde or they're given to the
Celestials based on whether or not
they're deviance or eternals and so
following that the question kind of
became who is
fulcrum right like like what is the
fulcrum how does it function okay so in
this this run of the Eternals which is
really more of the eternal and celestial
war what you ended up getting was this
really cool scenario where you got TM
ooh the Dreaming celestial now for the
purpose of our discussion the dreamy
Celestials not super important in this
story he's probably the single most
important character but for our
discussion he's not overly important
here what is important is that somewhere
along the line one of the Eternals a
woman by the name of Circe basically
ends up dying where she is look kind of
sacrificing her life and when that
happens she ends up in this in this
place called the vestibule which is
basically just like this giant bar more
or less and inside this bar is a guy who
basically identifies himself as a man
named Jack and the funny thing about
this is that the conversation between
the two it's fairly light-hearted
insofar as when when she wakes up you
know when she wakes up in this place
Jack offers her a drink and the two of
them kind of start talking and what Jack
says is that this place the vestibule is
essentially where Eternals go when they
die right like when they're when their
physical forms are destroyed because of
the fact that they are inherently
immortal when their physical forms are
destroyed their essence travels to the
vestibule and it encounters the fulcrum
and when that happens the fulcrum
essentially presents them with a choice
either they can be reborn back on earth
you know as per their immortality or
they can pass on to Lucinda I think is
what it's called basically their
afterlife where they can pass on to like
their version of Valhalla or heaven or
whatever you want to call it but
basically kind of live on in eternity in
that particular area
now with that having been the case of
course Circe basically ends up kind of
returning there but the big takeaway and
really the information that kind of
comes in the form of the fulcrum more or
less being an aspect of the of the one
above all comes by way of a conversation
that takes place between the Dreaming
celestial and the fulcrum and in this
instance when the dreaming celestial
dies when it arrives inside the
vestibule it immediately kind of asks
the question like are you the fulcrum
and the response of the fulcrum is yes
that is Who I am and so the way that
fulcrum kind of addresses the dreaming
celestial is you know the dream eusocial
says I think I might be broken and the
fulcrum basically asks why and the
dreaming celestial says because my
programming is changing now the reality
of this is that these Celestials are
basically beings that are for the most
part impartial the idea of right and
wrong good and evil don't really apply
to them instead it's just kind of like
they're beings who are there and they do
things that's basically it but what this
does is kind of like you
you know why do you think your
programming is is screwed up and the
dreaming celestial says because now I'm
no longer making decisions that are
completely and totally unbiased I'm
making decisions that seem to be kind of
irrational they don't really make any
sense to me and and one of the things
you know he basically says I'm coming
here to make an irrational request and
the request of the of the fulcrum he it
basically asks why why you know before I
do any of this before I answer or
fulfill your request the first question
is why the dreamy celestial basically
says because I care and what this means
is the dreamy celestial essentially
transcended its current role right and
move beyond its role and that's when you
start getting information about the
fulcrum and what the fulcrum really kind
of reveals here and there's a you know
the reason why I kind of provided some
backup here is to give some context but
also because like a 30-second video kind
of sucks and so the the fulcrum
essentially identifies itself as this
being that basically created the
Celestials right like I created all of
you guys at the same time it created the
Horde and so that's where things get
kind of ambiguous here because on one
side the fulcrum almost appears to be
this kind of you know Universal entity
but at the same time the fulcrum kind of
speaks in such a way as I created all
things in existence all that there is
it's created by me right I've been here
we kind of talked about having seeded
multiple worlds over the course of all
of existence different things like that
but the general gist of this is that the
fulcrum created the Celestials and the
Horde to be a counterbalance that the
Celestials create life and the Horde
destroys life and so the results of this
is that the fulcrum had basically been
spending all this time waiting for one
of the Celestials to kind of become
self-aware essentially to become
autonomous to basically question its
role like what am I supposed to do you
know how does all this work and so
that's really kind of the last you see
of the fulcrum here that's basically it
it extends an offer to the dreamy
celestial would you like to come with me
and then we don't really get anything
after that now a lot of us because the
Eternals run was kind of cut short but
the fact remains that the fulcrum is
basically this like multiversal being
that kind of appears to be a version of
the one above all but it's never
definitively explained here well we're
never given a true and definitive answer
instead it's one of these things where
it's just kind of left to the readers
interpretation the conventional wisdom
as it exists now or maybe just common
knowledge as it exists now among fans
it's kind of like the fulcrum is
basically an aspect of the one above all
but there's no real information to
verify that there's no information that
really states either way it's just
generally accepted by the comic book
community which is probably one of the
worst things you can base your knowledge
on that is you know people just kind of
see it
that way right I guess it's really the
only thing we do have until we have
definitive information that kind of
verifies that but at the moment he's
just kind of a being that's there now
how the fulcrum exists insofar as Marvel
Comics right now we don't know and
there's really no reason to believe that
it does exist you know we can just kind
of go forward and do our thing but the
general gist here when it comes to the
fulcrum is that we can kind of just go
with the idea that it is essentially the
one above all or at least it's it's
viewed as being an aspect of the one
about all there's no definitive
information to verify that there's no
definitive information to show that it's
true we just kind of generally accept
that as the comic book community so I
don't know anyway I thought it'd be kind
of an interesting video kind of throw
out there and and just sort of prison -
you guys will dive far more in depth
into the Eternals as we get closer to
the film to the release of the movie
right so what will make sense of all of
that stuff because even on this channel
and even with my most die-hard fans if
they haven't read the Eternals and they
don't know anything about him they
haven't learned it any other from me
all right aside from maybe a few things
that we've talked about here and there
but we've never really had an in-depth
comprehensive discussion on the the
Eternals as a team so we will at some
point you know as a race explaining them
and all that kind of good stuff before
right now I figured this would be kind
of a cool little conversation so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explain - make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]